intérieurement même ceux qui veulent
nous parler mon il hésite un peu par
rapport aux autres
bonjour
[Musique]
oui à 96 je vous lis que nous nous
rendons notre secteur les bosquets reçu
[Musique]
votre immeuble tout est mûr et la wii la
plupart des appartements sont murées
bien évidemment ce genre d'immeuble
permet aux jeunes d'avoir des idées clan
et ce cachet assez facilement alors pour
nous il obtient même le sol et général
on va en discuter à naples et non sur le
bâtiment
alors là nous avons quelques boîtes aux
lettres
normalement une clé pour les ouvrir
les portes et des projets les
convocations elle est bien souvent les
noms n'apparaissent pas sur des les
boîtes aux lettres ça nous pose de
nombreux problèmes
vous avez regardé en l'air quand vous
êtes sorti par mesure de sécurité
souvent les jeunes quand ils nous voient
les images simples et la compte que l'on
forme et du haut de l'immeuble ne peut
nous lancer des pierres ou des
bouteilles de verre c'est qu'à 5/6
manque souvent n'ont pas pas
régulièrement mais ça arrive ça arrive
alors quelques mesures de sécurité par
exemple on marche rarement de ce
trottoir là on va sur l'autre
j'étais petit les jeunes voir parce que
le message va passer
au cours
donc août
comme vous pouvez le constater le
message passe très mal
un
endroit où je travaillais avant son
interpellation une conduite au poste
mais ici picard
mais tout dépend des circonstances les
individus sont isolés on peut les
interpeller mais dans ce cas là il vaut
mieux être
faire intervenir un salut général qui
avec elle et ils peuvent facilement
quitter les lieux rapidement est un
individu puisque la pied automatiquement
ça créerait créerait à l'affrontement et
un affrontement très important avec les
jeunes de la cité
et vous parlez il nous arrive quand même
d'avoir quelques relations des jeunes
surtout surtout en dehors de la cité
quand même devant la cité intérieurement
même ceux qui veulent nous parler mon il
hésite un peu par rapport aux autres
bonjour
moi mais c'est sûr que la configuration
les immeubles vacants ça fait penser
plus tôt avec l'aja coule qu'autre chose
découragés ont parfois c'est quand même
quand vraiment le contact passe quoi dû
parfois à caussade avril mais enfin il
ya le côté négatif mais il ya aussi
toujours un côté positif tous les jeunes
ne sont pas
comme ça réticent à voir quelques
relations
et ce en pense quoi
[Musique]